visage voilé et transparence de voile
laisse deviner ici une jambe chez saint
laurent
là un buste plus discret derrière les
fleurs séchées rêve
arrogant chez christian dior
réminiscence des années lippi la
bohemian joue la couleur et les foulards
chez christian lacroix
elle devient tahitienne chez saint
laurent chez ferron broderie et sur
broderies des collections brillante
françois lesage le plus connu au monde
pour ses broderies a beaucoup plus vrai
chez saint laurent cappe pas là toréador
robe comme des habits de lumière
1 1
inspiration espagnol aussi chez
christian lacroix
broderies discrète chez chanel
somptueuse sherer transparent en tout
près du corps comme une seconde peau
comme à moscou la transparence est aussi
à la mode